si él está un paso más cerca del
matrimonio igualitario tras que la
cámara de diputados aprobara el proyecto
un votos a favor 30 en contra y 2
abstenciones el proyecto deberá pasar
ahora al senado la cámara donde se
originó para un último paso y de ser
aprobado se convertiría en ley contempla
además la adopción por parte de niños
por parte de las parejas del mismo sexo
que tendrían los mismos derechos que el
resto de los matrimonios en el país el
reconocimiento de la maternidad a las
personas trans y las pensiones de viudez
para las parejas del mismo sexo el
proyector se retoma así después de
llevar varios años dormido en el
congreso fue ingresado en el segundo
mandato de michelle bachelet llevaba más
de cuatro años ahí esperando a ser
tramitado y sebastián piñera sorprendió
a todos en su última cuenta pública al
anunciar que le iba a poner máxima
prioridad algo que causó mucho enojo en
el oficialismo puesto que las fuerzas
conservadoras en el país se oponen al
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
no así la ciudadanía según expresan
varias encuestas además en la misma
sesión de la cámara de diputados- estaba
previsto que se discutiera el aborto la
despenalización a las 14 semanas de
gestación no puede ocurrir el tiempo
en la discusión del matrimonio
igualitario y quedará por tanto
postergada son dos temas que se discuten
en el congreso mientras en el país ya se
disputa la campaña por la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales que
opone a dos candidatos que tienen
también visiones contrapuestas en torno
a estos temas mientras que el
ultraderechista jose antonio kast
rechaza el matrimonio entre personas del
mismo sexo y cualquier tipo de aborto el
izquierdista gabriel boric se muestra a
favor de ambos proyectos